we're just honored to have herb here and
it's a wonderful pleasure for me to
introduce him however briefly and the
reason I say briefly because he is a
world-famous fellow as many of you know
also a very likable guy and I think
we're all going to experience that today
at this at this meeting I do want to
give you just a little bit of background
that I've learned about herb but some
things I already knew and some things I
learned in preparing for this one is
that he was born in Haddon Heights New
Jersey
he went to Connecticut Wesleyan
University from New Jersey he
subsequently then went to the NYU Law
School joined the New Jersey Supreme
Court as an employee after law school
and practice law from that venue for a
couple of years until he and his wife
decided they wanted to move of all
places to Texas they moved to Texas and
I didn't know
he joined a law firm in San Antonio
Texas that specialized in nurturing
among other things in nurturing
entrepreneurs and at that law firm he
met a guy named Rowland King who came in
and who had a revolutionary idea that
they might start an airline that would
charge
guess what low fares I might say at
Continental we consider that a little
subversive but they did it they did that
and sort of wrecked it for everyone I
might add but at that time it's hard for
us to remember that fares in the United
States were not a matter of the free
market they were controlled by something
called the C a B the Civil Aeronautics
Board and Airlines filed for fares on a
regular basis and generally got the
fares they asked for and fares got right
up there but there was a little bit of
room there was a little bit of an escape
clause which had to do with the fact
that the Civil Aeronautics Board only
regulated fares on interstate airlines
on interstate transport so herb and
Rowling King had the notion that if they
didn't fly interstate maybe they could
come in with low fares and and they
filed to start Southwest Airlines which
was going to fly within the state of
Texas between San Antonio and Dallas and
Houston Dallas and Houston Italy and of
course the other airlines in Texas in
that great American tradition said this
must be against the law and challenged
it and tried to get Southwest put out a
business herb as a lawyer was the key
player in fighting that lawsuit and
eventually won and put them out of
business at least temporarily
not intentionally I his his list of
innovations is just just tremendous he
he is the man in subsequent Lee Rowland
King gave up the CEO job herb left the
law firm became CEO of Southwest
Airlines in 1978 until 2001 when he
passed the baton to another CEO and is
currently the chairman of Southwest
Airlines with another CEO who he has
nurtured over the years now in charge
his innovations are legendary and I'm
only going to say just a few of them the
first was the 15-minute turnaround on an
airplane nobody thought that could be
done they did it one class of service
instead of two or three classes of
service no reserved seats serving
satellite airports instead of the the
major airports in a number of the cities
that they serve no meals peanuts instead
with peanut fares a single aircraft type
Airlines at that time we're famous for
having a different aircraft almost for
every pilot employee spot newest
spontaneity the notion that somehow work
should be fun and most of all low low
fares he pioneered that segment of the
industry and gave rise to a whole new
industry within an industry which is
something that we now call LCCs which is
low cost carriers and the list goes on
and on the company's now eight billion
dollars in sales who would have believed
it in those early days a half a billion
dollars in profits last year which is
about a half a billion more than all the
other airlines
professor we have two sets of bull yeah
yeah we actually teach there
well they have their they have 31,000
employees and I might say that while
he's come a long way and is one of the
few executives in America that has has
made the transition from being really a
founder and an entrepreneur to a person
who managed a company with north of
30,000 employees and sales encroaching
on ten billion dollars I mean that is a
tremendous career a tremendous career
and I hope we can get a little bit of a
flavor for that today he still has a
wonderful interest in entrepreneurship
having endured
I've excuse me endowed the entrepreneur
Center at the University of Texas in
Austin herb thank you very much for
coming today well thank you for having
me we are wonderful to be with you
now the the format that he chose today
was rather than giving a talk to to
invite me to ask him some questions
which I will do but most of all I want
to ask just one or two questions and
then I want to invite questions from the
audience today and and herb welcomes
that one of the things that herb this
this may be kind of an unusual question
but one of the things that you've said
and I as a finance professor have tried
to to get my arms around this you've
said employees come first customers come
second and stockholders come last that's
not exactly the way I teach it
and well I guess I'm gonna have to take
over that class III wondered I wonder
given that whether you think it would be
a step forward in America if we had that
more reflected in boards of directors
for example I notice your board of
directors is not populated very much by
customers although they may fly but
they're they're elected by the stock O's
the customers don't elect the board the
employees don't elect the board the
stockholders elect the board do you
think that's a mistake you think we
should have more of the European system
where employees elect board members and
maybe even customers elect board members
I don't we've experimented with that
some of the United States professors as
you well know United was a disastrous
experimentation with employee ownership
we were the progenitors of employee
ownership we had the first profit
sharing plan in the airline industry in
introduced in 1973 and just give you an
illustration of what that's meant to our
people we had one of our captains that
retired a couple of years ago and took
eight million dollars with him just from
his profit sharing plan not including
his 401k plan where we have a full 7.3
percent match but we've always felt that
it's very important to have your
employees as owners of the organization
but not controllers of the organization
because sometimes when you come out of a
particular environment that tends to be
your total focus you tend to be a little
tunnel visioned and I don't think it's
worked out too well at other airlines
where they for instance had labor
leaders on their board that have a very
special interest in the well-being of
their own constituency customers
generally speaking also tend to have
somewhat of a narrow focus and we're
looking for people that have more of a
worldview I think on our board and we're
looking for people that are very
diversified in their interests so that
they can bring from their own activities
a broader scope to our board and so
that's kind of the way we've always felt
about it as I said we were the
progenitors of employee ownership in the
airline industry we were the first but
we never thought that meant that
employees should control the company and
number two as far as customers are
concerned we bring them in to interview
our prospective new hires but what I
meant by the narrow sliver of focus
instead of having us you know a global
view is that when they talk to me about
coming in and interviewing our new hires
prospective hires they always want to
interview the flight attendants I mean
nobody ever says to me hey herb I will
come in and interview mechanics you know
or I want to interview the pilots they
always want to interview the flight
attendants and that's what I mean by
having sort of a narrow focus on things
that we tried to a walk
okay the other thing that of course
comes across partly in this introduction
and and just in your whole persona in
your whole career there's that you've
been a fabulous innovator I mean just
just thinking out of the box all the
time I'm wondering in your experience
whether there anything that you might
have to say about the extent to which
that spirit of innovation that passion
for innovation can be learned can be
taught or do you think it's simply
congenital are you born with it you know
that is a fascinating question because I
have pondered over that myself and the
way I've always viewed it is I think you
have to have that spark in your DNA to
start off with that you're a little bit
of a risk-taker you're a little bit of
visionary you're a little bit of an
idealist but I do think that it's
helpful at the college level for
instance to be exposed to that type of
thinking it may ignite a fire that
wasn't there I think it can teach you a
good bit about the pitfalls that you can
avoid when you're trying to to start
something and so I think that courses in
entrepreneurship at the college level
can be very helpful in that respect but
on the other hand there's no point in
doing it if your basic objective in life
is to be a third-level executive at a
huge corporation that would be a waste
of time but you know it is the smaller
companies the startup companies the new
companies that are creating the jobs and
creating the wealth in America as the
old line companies downsize and so I
think that anything we can do to
encourage that innovative and trepan
oriole spark is good and one of the
things that you do and then I'll shut up
you know I'm Irish so I just talk y'all
hear me at midnight but after a quart of
Wild Turkey
I'm saying guys I spoke to the airforce
and this it you think I'm a novice huh
novice I know what asymmetric means I've
been asymmetric midnight for 55 years
it's a new term to you but not to me but
as your company gets bigger I think you
want to have a cluster of people that
you really encourage and stimulate to
continue to be entrepreneurial and
innovative in their thinking and one of
the ways you do that by the way is never
spawning an idea because when you score
an idea you ensure that you'll never get
another one from that person and we try
to show the respect that we have for
anybody's ideas our rule is that you get
an answer in a week if you can and get
in touch with anybody Gary Kelly me
Coleen Barrett doesn't make any
difference you get an answer back in a
week because we want to know that we
respect you as a person and we respect
your thought process and we want you to
come back with additional ideas and the
other thing is we never just say no you
know no as an exercise of power I have
the power to say no and I've just done
it and we're not doing anything about it
we send lengthy explanations to our
employees about the testing that we've
done and why we're not adopting this
idea and how it was tried at some other
carrier proved to be a disaster so it's
always a reason to turn down rather than
just an arbitrary peremptory turned down
and that's one way you can stimulate
those ideas I'll give you an example
President Parker we had quite a crisis
in the airline industry where the FAA
ruled that you had to take some seats
out you know to provide more room for
access to the over-the-wing exits and
all the carrier's we just hope my lord I
mean this is going to be a crushing
burden and you know we're losing a lot
of our seats and so one of our mechanic
sent me a little diagram said herb I
figured out how we can add a seeds
and still comply with this rule just out
of the blue when the other carriers were
coming up with continental light United
shuttle etc they threw us all out of
their computer reservation systems GDS
its global distribution systems and and
the American Society of travel agents
asked to came to see me and they said we
have to handwrite tickets on Southwest
Airlines you know we can't also generate
tickets and I said well how about if we
just do without tickets you know if you
don't need a ticket you know I have to
write anything out and they said all
that would work pretty well and then
they left and I said okay now how do we
do that and four of our people
unbeknownst to me on their own time had
been working on how to do it
for about a year and a half and we
brought it up with these split so didn't
have to write any tickets we didn't have
any let me let me have axiomatic I guess
let me have a follow up question on on
the innovation question and then I want
to invite a question from from the
audience here one of the things you said
right off the bat is that you have to
have a a culture that's friendly to
risk-taking yes and and I I think all of
us know that and have heard that and and
of course risk-taking means just what it
says risk what has been your biggest
screwup amidst all your successes where
was something that went awry and how
fast did you recognize it what'd you do
about it
well I think Southwest Airlines biggest
screwup was hiring me haha that's number
one that looms over everything else does
everest looms over the serengeti but
what I remember what I remember is a
story about Thomas Watson which I know
you've heard but I just loved it visa
fee the point that you're making this is
what we've always followed at Southwest
Airlines vice president of IBM came in
and said mr. Watson I've got a
tremendous idea of course this was long
ago this is original mr. Watson and I
want to set up this little division to
work on it and I need ten million
dollars you know to get it started well
it was a total failure and the guy came
into mr. Watson he said you know I
proposed this additional business this
line of business you gave me ten million
dollars we've lost it it's a failure and
here's my resignation and mr. Watson
said hell no I just spent ten million on
your education I ain't gonna let you
leave and essentially that's what
Southwest Airlines has done and very
quick recovery if you make a mistake
don't sit around and mourn about it I
don't dwell on it don't destroy yourself
just correct it lickety-split as fast as
you possibly can because with mistakes
recovery time is very important and
there's no ego involved you know many
corporations really weigh themselves
down they walk around with stones
hanging around them because I said oh my
gosh we did this and if we stop doing it
too quickly we'll be embarrassed
that's institutional worship that's
saying what we're concerned about is the
reputation of the institution and its
appearance rather the results that you
achieve in the field and companies that
fall into institutional worship probably
won't be around very long and don't buy
any of their stock okay right there yeah
- you
it's a very good relations with your
labor unions yes becoming on nice how
you foster those relationships or how
you being able to maintain that record
well everybody here that question has to
do okay yeah actually I think the key to
that is that we have never treated our
labor unions and we've been the most
heavily unionized airline in the
industry for quite some time
we've never treated them as adversaries
we've always treated them as partners
because if that canoe goes down we're
all going to go down with it and when I
say that I don't mean just in a
perfunctory superficial way when we hold
company events we invited all the labor
union leaders to come to them because
they're part of the company too if they
have an issue we take care of it as
quickly as we possibly can remember they
have a political constituency as well
called their membership and I'll give
you an example of what I mean being
sensitive to who they are and the
problems that they have one of our
captains who was ahead of swapper
Southwest Airlines Pilots Association
came in and said her mom under a lot of
fire from the membership and I said well
we got to distract him
and I said why don't you write a letter
to the membership just attacking the
hell out of me so he did that all of a
sudden I was getting all the fire was
off him he was a great guy he
appreciated that now
a number of our officers rat is did you
see this letter that Jon Snow brick
wrote about you I said well yeah I kind
of did I wrote it in other words having
a little realism recognizing that the
people that you're dealing with have you
know their responsibilities too and
being very cognizant of their needs and
they reciprocate they respond to that
very very well and it's interesting
because after you've established a
relationship of trust and understanding
a couple of times we've had leaders that
probably were not too conducive to the
well-being of Southwest Airlines as a
whole and their own membership as both
an out of office without any urging or
effort on our part and I think that's a
real tribute to the kind of relationship
that we have I think it's absolutely
right Southwest say Union relationships
have been absolutely exemplary and and
in many instances quite unusual and a
lot of that does stem from from your
philosophy about that which which comes
across loud and clear we have fights but
not then that is you know we yell we
throw things we get a contract and it's
behind us it's not like the Jukes in the
cowlick acts of the Hatfields and McCoys
you know that they're feuding with each
other for generations and still killing
each other for reasons they can't even
remember but usually you keep flying
while you're doing that yeah we do we do
and I'll tell you what I said to our
pilots last time I wanted to negotiate a
contract with them and I said gentlemen
I want to tell you right at the outset I
will not take advantage during these
negotiations of the fact that I know
that you would do this for nothing
that's where pilots come from they want
to fly yeah
yes right here phenomenal time building
this exceptional business I'd like to
know what's been your worst day it works
well you know this is going to sound a
little
pollyannish but I've never had a worse
day at work I really haven't I mean the
worse things are the better I feel about
it and more useful I feel in trying to
get him
you know corrected and get him changed
and we brought in a guy one time I
didn't bring him in professor somebody
else did I talked to our leadership
group but he said you know the way you
handle this is if there's something you
don't like to do take that monkey off
your back and put it on somebody else's
within the company and I said get your
ass out of here I don't want to see you
again so if you enjoyed the
responsibilities if you enjoy the
challenges if that's the kind of thing
that makes you passionate you don't have
bad days that's an unusual answer right
yeah yes over here versus you talk a
little bit about your passion what
fundamental
second question can you give your
perspective yeah what drives me is the
desire to do right by other people and
to serve them with excellence and it's
just a question of satisfying my own
inner need to be excellent and to serve
people well and it doesn't matter what
you're doing I don't care what it is it
could be very inconsequential but if
you're trying to help somebody else out
if you're trying to improve their lives
if you're trying to help them even
psychologically you work as hard as you
possibly can
in order in order to accomplish that and
that's driven by I thinking inner inner
need to help people and to do it in a
very worthwhile way and leadership I
think basically consists of that and
people say they don't have any passion
for what they do well I think if you're
doing something for somebody else
I don't have any passion for what I do
for myself you know that's why I lose my
car for three days doesn't make any
difference because I can't find my keys
you know so it's immaterial but I'll
stay up 48 hours in a row trying to get
something right for somebody else and if
you have that passion to be a servant
everything you do is infused with
passion
yes right there like you would have like
systems you know technology is that what
you're talking about the same way
essentially there's no difference you
have to adapt different tactics but your
behavior is the same we just exerted
ourselves in different ways to
communicate with their employees they
send other people into the field as
ambassadors or missionaries to go around
and talk to our employees in person in
the various sections areas of our system
each year to put in a daily
communication to all of our employees
instead of just a monthly communication
to have an intranet and just all kinds
of ways of communicating Plus making
sure that our officers get out of the
general office and actually load bags on
the airplane take reservations at the
reservation center and it's amazing what
an education they get when they actually
have to perform those functions and so
that's the way that you do it but the
main thing is that it has to be job one
it can't slip to being job two three
four or five because then you've lost it
no matter how big you get taking care of
your employees being interested in your
employees communicating with your
employees honoring your employees is
still job one
well to the international air
transportation Association in Washington
recently I was quite surprised that they
asked me to do that I rented an Italian
suit so that they would think I was more
cosmopolitan than I really am but it's a
ranking of priorities with what we do
and the way that we do it we think that
we still have tremendous opportunities
still available to us domestically in
the United States we haven't gone into
Newark yet for instance don't try
but it's it's my old home I know yeah
it's ah wolf you can't go home again
okay
Philadelphia is your home Safari told in
Philadelphia I told of us that you know
Philadelphia was my big city when I grew
up that before he get too chesty and
egotistical about that remember the
other choice was Camden but that's not
high on our list of priorities I'm not
going to say that we will never do it
don't misunderstand me but when you
cannot when you can open raleigh-durham
as an example and on day one operate
with a 4.3 percent load factor it's just
easier to do you don't have to worry
about exchange rates you don't have to
worry about international security you
don't have to worry about language
issues and some carriers have said to me
they said well why don't you just do
this out of San Antonio you know that
would be a problem if you just stayed
out of San Antonio say well suppose
somebody comes up and wants to buy a
ticket in Amarillo to go through San
Antonio to to Mexico as an example in
other words you have to change your
whole system and thus far it hasn't been
the most productive thing that we think
that we could do so it's never say never
but it's just not up there towards the
top of our priorities like Newark it'd
be alright if you said never herb yeah
it's in the back loses all its
personality and culture true or false
oh absolutely
no question about that blood I could
answer that definitively
yeah
yeah yeah my cousin back there they left
others can imitate Southwest is this
fall oh yeah uh can others imitate
Southwest Airlines business model yes
there have been two generations of
imitators there were a number of
carriers during the 1980s that said they
were going to be the next Southwest
Airlines they would apply to the CA B
and they've mentioned Southwest Airlines
26 times and their applications but they
they they weren't very profound I mean
you know they looked at little things
and said this is Southwest Airlines when
actually it's a huge mosaic composed of
thousands of pieces and so they didn't
do very well they basically disappeared
this new generation is much more astute
and much more knowledgeable the
jetblue's the air trans and they're
really doing they're doing a good job
and they have varied from our model to
some extent but it's more of a tactical
rather than as strategic a departure and
that's one of the things that we have to
really keep our eye on from a
competitive standpoint as well as Newark
I want I want to ask a question to just
just plug one in right here I getting
back to a little bit of the financial
angle not not not withstanding all the
other dimensions here but some people
have observed many people to observe
that if you take the cumulative profits
in the airline business since the
beginning of flying the profits and the
losses all added up at nets to zero or
maybe a little less than zero
why does capital still flow into this
industry where do you see the
opportunity our people invest in this
industry out of their minds
what either what professor Parker I have
pondered that question because it is
really a horrible business okay you know
it's it's capital intensive labor
intensive fuel intensive intensely
cyclical tremendously competitive you
know your capital assets travel at 500
miles an hour
yeah not shoe factories the government
tells you what you can do in the air and
on the ground every day you know whether
you can take off whether you push back
when you can take off what direction you
go what altitude how to process your
passengers you know as a result of 9/11
and I'll tell you what my theory is
because you're right there's always a
lot of capital ready to flow in to the
business and I think it's people who
can't buy a professional football team a
professional basketball team or
professional baseball team and they say
well I just got to have a hobby and so
they start an airline and most times it
turns out to be hobby as a matter of
fact I counseled Carl Icahn
when he was at TWA during a industry
gathering and call was calling you know
he just couldn't believe it he said you
know it's crazy yes the revenues come in
two hundred million dollars below what
they protect the cost come in two
hundred million dollars higher and I
asked him what are you going to do they
said we're going to get more airplanes
and fly our way out of this and so I
told I told Carl I said I can save you
millions in psychiatric fees
and this is the story I told them I said
you know the two guys in the dress
business in New York and the older one
retires and he goes to Miami and you
know he buys a condo and the younger the
younger guy younger partner is still
working he comes to see them he says you
know what do you do for a hobby you know
do you play highligh now you go to
nightclubs know that chase women know
well everybody's got to have a hobby
what do you do it says I raise bees
since you're raised bees how can you
raise bees in a condo in Miami
he says easy let's go out and get some
bees put them in a shoebox blew it up on
the shelf of my closet I got my bees got
my hobby don't off I go the other
partner said well don't they die and I
said you have it's cruel it's just a
hobby well that's what I told Carl I
said just to preserve your sanity just
think of it as a hobby you want a
question yeah
to have a work-life balance I'm sorry I
couldn't hear work-life balance is it
possible to have a work-life balance in
your position if so can you talk a
little bit of how you balance your life
oh yeah well you know it is possible to
have balance first of all you have to
have about four hours a day for drinking
[Music]
make sure that is sacrosanct and nobody
trifles with it but basically the way
I've always balanced my life is by
working probably 16 to 18 hours a day
and making sure that I did everything
that my kids did four of them at the
same time never missed any event that
they ever had any Christmas dinner etc
but I would go back to the office
on Christmas and worked for six or eight
hours till 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning
go to the office Saturday night and
Sunday to balance those things
fortunately I didn't need a lot of sleep
and that's really true I used to sleep
five hours you know less so that's how I
balanced it
now how would you grade that answer yes
I have a question here isn't that bounce
a new division for an airline which was
founded a lot of principles that I'm
sure many consider impossible to say the
15-minute turnaround different types of
plane back you start out ten ten minute
turnaround now that they remembered the
fuel yeah yeah we got tired of that how
did you get your employees your
investors oh well I'll tell you you just
have to be confident of what you're
doing did not pay any attention to it
I was excoriated by the outside world
the financial community in New York for
a decade as an example I have to do
regulation because they said well you
know you got to be what you got to be
like American you got to be like United
there was some think tank in Washington
I think most of our drunk tanks you know
and anybody that has a Big Chief tablet
the crayon is an intellectual but
he said there's six things that you've
got to have an order survive and I ran
around saying I guess I'm going to have
to communicate with everybody through a
Swami because we don't have anyone in
the six and we're not going to and you
have to be strong enough to withstand
that and finally Mike Dirnt chin from it
was then at first Boston Mike got up Oh
in 1990-91 and he said you know he said
for the last decade we've been telling
her how to run his airline and for the
last decade
herb has been ignoring us and it's the
most prosperous airline in the world do
you think maybe it's time to stop
telling her how to run his airline those
things that were bothered me bill any
way shape or form because all the people
that were telling me those things were
expressing conventional wisdom and if
it's conventional and ain't wisdom and
if it's wisdom
it ain't conventional yes following 9/11
the airline industry was certainly in
bad straits and most of them did it very
very poorly but it's my remember that
Southwest actually was able to continue
turning a profit yes we were we continue
to turn a profit how can you talk about
what leadership you have roles you had
to provide to your employees and all
when everyone was talking about how the
industry was just going to plummet well
I've been asked to repeat the question
particularly for some of the people in
the front question was after 9/11 almost
all the airlines lost money
Southwest did not lose money how did
they do that and what was the leadership
style that did that yeah well I'll tell
you it wasn't so much leadership style
although we are very good at responding
to emergencies but it's actually a
philosophy that involves a sense of
historicity in a sense of Futurity and
that is that things happen bad things
happen more often than not in the
airline industry and anybody that knows
anything about it knows that
there's going to be at least two crises
every decade now what does that mean
Oh we'd better be ready for that aha an
amazing idea
so my slogan has always been we managed
in good times so that will do well in
bad times just to give you an
illustration of what I'm talking about
when fuel was real low jet fuel I said I
think we're deceiving ourselves with
respect to how well we're doing on our
costs in other words because jet fuel so
low our costs really look low but take
jet fuel out and how are we doing oh we
got a problem with escalating costs that
was when the industry is making record
profits so when 9/11 happened when it
took place we had the lowest cost per
available seat mile in the US airline
industry we had the strongest balance
sheet in the US airline industry we had
proportionally the most liquidity of any
airline in the industry and so as a
consequence we were prepared semper
paratus always prepared
that's only Latin I know by the way I
don't want to deceive you after all I'm
not practicing law now but
but it's been ready so there were no
furloughs as soon as do t allow us to
come back up and brought all the planes
up didn't cancel any flights and what
about our business because we were ready
yes a lot of the audience and a lot of
us are thinking about how best to
approach our careers in kind of you know
exploring our dreams and passions etc do
you have an advice for you know people
in front of our age group how we should
think about our careers in our lives and
we have a corollary question kind of
what matters most to you if you don't
come to Stanford you just labeled
yourself as a dummy
alright are you prepared to be invited
back almost every week I would love it
yeah I and the second question is what
advice do you have for people of the age
cohort that are the admits here and and
what matters to you in life and and work
and what matters to you most I guess
well first of all I wouldn't be too
serious about things and I think that
keeps things in proportion be open be
curious be inquisitive and it's amazing
how things will just come out of left
field you'll say haha you know this is
my passion this is my future so I would
say always keep your mind open to new
experiences to new learning what you're
in whether you're in college or not
after you get out it shouldn't stop when
you graduate you're just better able to
appreciate it so I think that's one
thing you know read a lot study a lot of
different fields looking a lot of
different ideas don't tap in and confine
yourself necessarily and I guess the
thing that was most important to me was
succeeding on behalf of other people you
know I couldn't charge clients fees
because I was so wedded to their cause
by the time we got finished I didn't
want to charge it because we're in this
together like the Marines and so all the
lawyers at the law firm refused to allow
the younger lawyers to come talk to me
about fees as a consequence of that but
I think sometimes we restrict ourselves
a little too much when we're perhaps a
little too young fortune had an article
some years ago that said most of the
successful business leaders of that time
had really only gotten into what they
finally did after they were 44 years of
age or more and so I think be flexible
be open be curious learn all the time
from other people and books I read
omnivorous Lee
yes the workplace what are some of your
interests and hobbies in addition to
drinking of course I'm not under oath
but I'm going to take the fifths anyhow
oh well hunting
I'll take what equine is okay there's an
island in Florida it's overrun with
iguanas yeah guys right down here yeah I
had a question why would you borrow your
travel arrangements how did you get here
to Stanford today now I want to tell you
this gentleman is having a near-death
experience
because of the restrictions of the
Wright Amendment serpent circumscribing
interstate service into and out of Love
Field in Dallas Texas and the age of
deregulation of the domestic industry so
that some unnamed carrier can charge
much higher fares at DFW Airport without
competition I flew another carrier
Oh wave goodbye to him remember those
iguanas I was talking about yes
yeah we always really focused on
quickness and simplicity is very helpful
that way you know the simply can simply
you keep your business the faster you
could the faster you can move but I
think one of the things that you have to
do is wage an unending fight against
bureaucracy and hierarchy because you
get bigger those things naturally tend
to propagate themselves and so you have
to look at every opportunity and say hey
wait a second no I'm sorry you're not
getting 12 extra people to handle this
program I'm sorry that we're not going
to do 1,000 different things that really
won't contribute much to the end result
that we're trying to achieve it's kind
of like oh I talked about the focus on
it it's kind of like you know the Army
Inspector General going to a tank corps
and giving them an a because all their
tanks are real nice and they're lined up
beautifully they look great none of them
run you know but the paperwork is all
done and it goes to another tank corps
and their tanks are all dirty
you know they look kind of scummy but
guess what they're ready to go into
battle we're looking for the second type
of tank you're going to have one last
question this is gone quickly but we
have to conclude one last question let
me have it right down here in the front
row yeah
the question is give us an anecdote or
an example where a petitioner your
employees was especially rewarding and
fulfilling to you well this is the kind
of thing we do and I use this as an
exemplar because of course there are
millions of things that we do for our
employees and have done for a great many
years but I'll just give you the flavor
of it one of our flight attendants from
Houston calls me and she's crying she
and her husband have separated and
because he didn't make the payments on
her car it's been repossessed
so I promptly call the legal department
and says you got a new case get that car
back for her today and they did that's
the kind of thing that Southwest
Airlines does for all of our people
every day well with that I think you can
understand why ever since herb was CEO
at Southwest it's been listed as one of
the 10 best places to work in America
[Applause]